barely a person as far as the eye can
see not what you'd expect on a Spanish
seafront in summer coronavirus made sure
of that
but it's all about to change not only
has Spain reopened its borders it's
allowing most European visitors
including Brits to come in without
facing 14 days of quarantine holiday
companies have already begun advertising
again although some travelers will take
some convincing obviously the the
customer confidence is is down the
people want to be on an aeroplane at
this present moment in time going
through the Security's in airports etc
etc so I can understand why people are a
little bit apprehensive but hopefully
you know as the virus reduces and
reduces and and the figures and
everywhere gets better their confidence
will come in that reluctance was
reflected in a recent survey 68% of
those asked said they were not prepared
to travel overseas in the next six
months 40% said they wouldn't want to go
by plane and only 11% said they'd travel
abroad if they'd have to spend a
fortnight in quarantine at Stansted
Airport in Essex it didn't take long for
flights to resume - the UK's favourite
holiday destination where four hundred
thousand British people have second
homes within hours of Spain scrapping
quarantine Ryanair had arranged its
first flights with passengers arriving
here in the early hours to head to the
likes of Malaga Barcelona and Gran
Canaria
on arrival travelers are simply asked to
confirm where they've come from provide
contact details and have a temperature
check but if the rules stand anyone
re-entering the UK would still face 14
days isolation on their return and
unpopular restriction which began on
June the 8th and won't be reviewed until
the 29th
Spain relies on its tourism and locked
up hotels and bars are bad for the
economy but the UK government is still
advising against all non-essential
international travel although the lure
of Sun and sangria is sure to be enough
to
many Emma Birchley skynews Stansted